dazzle africa is hosting their let's get
wild gala this saturday and there's
still time for you to get involved here
tell us more is stacy james the ceo of
dazzle africa and alex he's one of the
performers thank you for joining us
thanks for having us you and i were
talking during the break dazzle africa
tell people more about the organization
so first of all dazzle is a group of
zebra okay you don't know that we're a
non-profit based in las vegas and we
support conservation education and clean
water in the country of zambia and we
host safaris that give back to all of
our projects it's amazing stuff you guys
are doing so what can we expect at the
gala on saturday night oh my gosh we
have over a hundred amazing auction
items silent and live auctions something
for everybody we have alex boy a
performing for us
we have incredible music we have
speakers from zambia and just it's a
meaningful and fun super fun night that
gives back it's going to be a special
night now now alex you're performing on
saturday night and you've brought your
drum with you and you're going to give
us a little something right now man this
is something that you know i'm from
nigeria the villagers they do this thing
called call and response okay and so
it's like when they're out in the
village you know they say their enemies
are coming they start banging their drum
how do you why heidi kits you know that
type of thing so so i'm gonna do a chop
right now right okay
so let's see let's see how i'm gonna
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
special okay so you can see alex
performing on saturday night just seeing
you there is gonna be a treat on
saturday let's circle back real quick
that was great some of these silent
auction items because you have a raiders
helmet here why do we have a raiders
helmet here in front of us adams has
been incredibly generous and we have a
package with all sorts of sign things
like his sign helmet
raiders tickets we have bruno mars
concert tickets and signs
auction um package with his albums we
have local zambian jewelry we have mass
we have
truly something for everyone but we have
a safari
so there are unlimited tickets for the
event on saturday if you want to go we
have four seats left four seats left but
here's the deal though the silent
auction is open to anybody you can jump
online at your house on saturday night
and bid on these items this weekend
correct absolutely i love it yeah just
go to the website click on gala 2022 and
then you can register from there
anywhere in the world thank you so much
for joining alex i want to talk about
your style man you have a dialed in my
friend you have a dial dude thank you so
much appreciate it rocky we'll send it
over to you